the Joe Rogan experience during the
campaign we want you know you talked
about our infrastructure crumbling what
the hell's been done on that front
nothing and also the that was that the
big one is the economy like the the debt
rather like how much we're in debt we're
in debt and more oh my god yeah
crippling 1.6 trillion for student debt
alone that's insane
what do you think about the people that
are calling out to try to eliminate
student debt I am a hundred percent on
board because it's possible absolutely
and you just tax Wall Street gambling
literally that can do it alone you do
not have household we mean by Wall
Street JAMA and Bernie laid it all out
he just read this morning on the way
here so I don't know the full proposal
but Wall Street just makes you know
billions of dollars I don't know how
often but just like betting on these
trading and [ __ ] like Wall Street just
makes so much money and if we just taxed
Wall Street or you know like you're
talking about taxing these defense
contractors or actually trying to change
the laws to not have these corporations
hide billions of dollars offshore and
tax havens it solves all of these
problems pretty quickly and it's not a
matter of how can we do it it's a matter
that we have to do it because students
are totally crippled there's no
opportunities in this country any
qualities the highest that it's been
since the Great Depression and that's a
huge problem we're not going to be able
to get people opportunities at all or a
better life it's also so crazy that you
do that to people that are 17 years old
right they don't have any idea what it's
gonna be like to be 35 and be
quarter-million-dollar did your parents
have student debt yeah they did yeah my
stuff my stepfather was in it was in
debt when he when he graduated from
school it just seems like it's getting
so exponential but not less yeah I mean
he handled it mm-hmm but it's what you
have today if you don't have any if you
don't have any grants and you just try
to go to school based on you know on
loans Greg Fitzsimmons was here what was
he saying his kids were it was sixty
plus thousand dollars a year for each
one of those kids two thousand I think a
year yeah and then there's each one of
his kids there's no jobs once you go and
you know right at a school right I mean
especially if you have anything
technologically related the idea that at
the
in the four years the technology is
gonna be relevant it's it's great right
exactly and then here's the crazy thing
like we all know that kids human beings
their frontal cortex doesn't even fully
developed by the time they're 25
[Applause]